[Music]
now to present the music world one of
the most a drug performers of this
generation a fine actor a man who has
brought art and grace to millions a
dancer of unparalleled skill mr. Gene
Kelly
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
which I can think of a line thread that
I can well
the nominations for the best scoring of
a musical picture are Annie Get Your Gun
metro-goldwyn-mayer by adolphe Deutsch
and Roger Eden's Cinderella grab Disney
Productions RKO radio by Oliver Alison
Paris Smith I'll get by 20th Century Fox
by Lionel Newman three little words
metro-goldwyn-mayer by Andre Previn and
the West Point story Warner Brothers by
Ray hind or the winners are Adolph
Deutsch and Roger Ramey's for Annie Get
Your Gun
[Applause]
Roger Agence has two previous Awards
Easter
on the cloud this is god-awful I think
first colleges
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Ovid arts accepted the award for himself
and Roger evening the nominations for
the best score of a dramatic or a comedy
picture are all about a 20th Century Fox
by Alfred Newman the flame in the arrow
Norma F our production Warner Brothers
by Max Steiner no sad songs for me
Columbia by George deunan Samson and
Delilah sussel B DeMille Paramount by
Victor young and Sunset Boulevard
paramount by fans walking on the winner
is fans Batman
[Applause]
[Music]
Ron's wife Linda Fida [ __ ]
[Music]
I'm deeply grateful to this honor and I
want to thank wrestling's to bracket you
survivor for inspiring me with their
production of Sunset Boulevard
thank you
nominations for the best song first used
in an eligible picture be my love from
the toast of New Orleans
metro-goldwyn-mayer
music by Nicolas Brodsky lyrics by Sammy
Kahn
bibbidi-bobbidi-boo from Cinderella Walt
Disney Productions RKO radio music and
lyrics by Mack David Al Hoffman and
Jerry Livingston Mona Lisa from captain
Cary USA paramount
music and lyrics by Ray Evans and Jay
Livingston mule train from singing guns
Paramount Pictures corporation Republic
music and lyrics by Fred Glickman high
heat and Jonny Lang and Wilhelmina from
Wabash Avenue 20th Century Fox music by
Joseph Murrow lyrics by Mack Gordon the
envelope and the winners are ray Evans
and Jay Livingston for Mona Lisa
[Applause]
Raven and Jay Litton was born a month
apart and went to college together and
Arkham even resemble each other with it
so they call Jay ray Raj
[Music]